guadar
is a strategically important point on
the map
of pakistan it sits very close to iran
actually
on the very southern coast it's about a
10 hour drive
west of karachi but it's only about an
hour drive to iran
the area is extremely poor it's very
arid
it doesn't have enough water electricity
has been
very spotty one of the most surprising
things about visiting gwadar is the high
degree of security
that is absolutely everywhere there are
armed guards that are required to escort
foreign visitors everywhere you go
because it is a contested region because
there have been
militant attacks in the past despite all
this
gwadar is a key part of the
china-pakistan economic corridor
also known as cpec the crown jewel of
president xi jinping's belt and road
initiative
we will leave no stone unturned in
ensuring that cpec
and all the projects under its umbrella
are materialized in time
and in full so far just one third of all
cpec projects have been completed
in gwadar none of them have been and the
promised improvements for local people
like job creation
and better infrastructure have not
materialized
so what has china got to gain from
developing this seemingly obscure city
on the pakistani coast
we have seen this movie before an
outside power comes into pakistan
it spends heavily on big infrastructure
projects
china's not the first to do it right
after pakistan became independent
in the late 1940s early 50s the u.s was
sending
advisors into pakistan to help plants
economy
us was doing infrastructure projects
there too
those early projects helped the us gain
pakistan as an ally against the soviet
union during the cold war
the u.s has provided about 80 billion
dollars in aid to pakistan since its
independence
but overall the result is disappointing
one of the recent attempts was in the
late 2000s as part of the us effort to
combat terrorism in afghanistan
the number one item on that aid package
was to build
these high visibility infrastructure
projects
so there there are literally projects
that the united states
tried to do or pakistan proposed to the
united states
in the 2000s during that period that
have become belt and road projects
china is stepping into a gap which has
been left
by retreating ambition from the
we could u.s farther and faster
the belton road initiative is china's
president xi jinping's
signature foreign policy initiative
launched in 2003. it comprises
an overland belt stretching through
china central asia into europe
and a maritime road stretching around
southeast asia through the india ocean
and up
past east africa so a benign way
of characterizing china's belton road
initiative
would be infrastructure for influence so
when xi jinping announced the belt and
road initiative
shortly afterwards china designated
pakistan
as its showcase flagship project so the
china-pakistan economic corridor was
going to be the biggest
and most important showcase for the
success
of the belton road pakistan is in great
need
of infrastructure development they
wanted to
create a railway a highway
roads all kinds of economic development
that is intended to help pakistan
and it's meant to provide jobs
2.3 million jobs for pakistanis it's
meant to provide a 2.5
boost to gdp growth and china would gain
economically as well
cpec was intended to reduce oil and gas
routes from the middle east by thousands
of miles
a way to cut over land into western
china instead of going around southeast
asia by ship
projects in pakistan also provide
chinese state-owned companies with an
additional market
chinese workers are brought to pakistan
to build infrastructure and then take
wages home
cpec is also strategically significant
for china and pakistan
china wants to strengthen this
relationship to counter their shared
rival india
cpec is both an instrument of chinese
power as well as a test
of chinese power if it succeeds
china will be demonstrating that it's
able to do
what great powers have not been able to
do in pakistan including the united
states
which is why gwadar is so important it's
in pakistan's balochistan province
an area with serious electricity and
water shortages
lujastan province is actually populated
by people
who are of baloch origin they're a
different
ethnicity they speak a different
language from
the majority in power in islamabad
and they feel as the poorest province in
pakistan
they have not sufficiently benefited
from some of the
economic achievements that the rest of
pakistan has had
that area is quite contested by
the belgian liberation army the people
who
feel that even pakistani people have
encroached into their territory
so quite a number of people are still
staging attacks and they attacked
the biggest international hotel in
gwadar
shot up the lobby and killed i think
five people
but this unsettled city is where the
china-pakistan economic corridor is
supposed to lead to
authorities plan to develop gwadar into
an international port city
gwadar port has an interesting history
and an interesting location too it's
located in baluchistan it's about 120
kilometers from iran
pakistan purchased this territory from
oman
i think in the 1950s and so for a long
time
pakistan has had on its agenda trying to
develop this area
since the 70s it's wanted to build a
port in gwadar
actually approached the united states in
the 1970s and tried to convince the
nixon administration
to pay for a report even offered naval
access if the united states was
willing to pay for that the u.s rejected
pakistan's offer
concerned that the port would not be
commercially viable and would cause
geopolitical tension
but in the early 2000s a chinese company
was awarded the contract to build the
port
and they completed phase one of
construction in 2006.
the port was then managed by a
singaporean government entity
in 2013 a chinese port operator took
over from the singaporeans
in 2015 china announced that it will
expand the port as part of the cpec
initiative but five years later little
has happened
when you look out at the port you can
see it has only three berths
and all of them were empty and the only
ship
that was in the port at the time was a
pakistan
naval frigate and so it indicated to me
that the port
is not particularly operational for
commercial purposes
and a number of analysts have talked
about the strategic importance in a
military sense
if eventually china were able to use the
port of gwadar
as a military base you know no one would
be surprised if
china did use it in that way i don't
think in the short term like it is set
up in djibouti where it has a permanent
base
i think it's more likely to use it as
almost like a sort of
forward-based resupply option
something it can use when it wants to
other projects like building pakistan's
largest airport in gwadar and two
special economic zones have been delayed
a 19 kilometer highway linking the port
with the makran coastal highway in
balochistan
is under construction too most of the
people who live there and work there
already are fishermen they rely on
access to the sea
the way that the highway express highway
from the port was originally proposed
would have cut off
their sea access and so that was a real
point of contention with the community
there have been some proposals to allow
them an underpass
it's still a little bit unclear how that
is finally going to be resolved
even if those projects are eventually
built there are serious questions about
who will work there
there is a problem with manpower of
course in guadalajara it's a very small
city and so one proposal has been well
we'll just
ship chinese workers in from china and
build
lots of fancy housing for them
the first chinese-built community in
pakistan
a 500 million dollar development
spanning over 10 million square feet
with over 60 open spaces that
kind of proposal is what makes a lot of
the
pakistani local people quite upset
a guadal-based journalist expressed
concerns to bloomberg over projects like
this
the journalist spoke anonymously for
fear of persecution from the pakistan
government
these projects are creating jobs but
they're not really creating jobs for the
local people of gwadar
they're not against economic prosperity
but they're against the development that
leaves them behind
an official at cpic the private real
estate investment company
said it's made significant investments
in the local community
and that employment for gwadar residents
remains a priority
pakistan doesn't have the money to build
these projects
it's gone to the imf for its 13th
bailout since the 1980s
by engaging in cpec projects the
government of pakistan has incurred more
debts from china
not only posing challenges for pakistan
but possibly the international community
if pakistan eventually defaults on its
debts
but cpec is still set to go on even if
most current projects haven't been
completed
the two countries have recently signed
new projects worth 11 billion dollars
pakistan's prime minister said the
country's economic future is linked with
china
[Music]
it's hard to imagine how the
china-pakistan economic corridor is
going to be the game changer
that the pakistan government would like
it to be
we're not seeing the economic growth or
benefit from the projects that were set
out we're supposed to have seen by now
we're not seeing the job creation
project delays accumulating debts
commercial viability
these problems of cpec are also typical
of belt and road projects around the
world
for china though it's never the narrow
accounting perspective that matters it's
the bigger
strategic benefits as china's dollars
continue to flow
as china's concrete continues to pour
china's influence
continues to increase
you